g'day everyone this is some subs youtube
channel and i'm lucas your aussie
instructor for surviving in the digital
jungle in previous videos the suave
bradley made about digital fingerprints
and information bubbles he mentioned
that many services use geolocation data
but what if you want to hide this
information about your address well
today we will compare four of the most
popular methods to do so and tell you
why none of them guarantee anonymity
[Music]
let's start with the most common way
people ensure anonymity private browsing
aka incognito according to statistics 46
of americans use it this mode first
appeared on safari in 2005 and a couple
years later other browsers caught on
today more than 40 of network users use
this mode for embarrassing searches
admit it you've also pressed command
shift n or control shift n more than
once but for what to prevent the use of
tracking mechanisms for search engines
and advertising networks to hide a
particular query from the search history
to preserve anonymity hydro ip address
and geo location data i have some bad
news for you it's not by chance that i
call this level zero incognito mode
doesn't really give you any anonymity at
all your computer and software still
have features that allow search engines
social networks and advertising networks
to uniquely identify you in private
browsing modes of course google pretends
that it doesn't recognize you but in
fact this isn't the case therefore for
example professional seo specialists
have long abandoned checking search
results in this mode and use much more
advanced tools instead
private browsing is not able to change
your ip address despite what your auntie
says
therefore the company that provides you
with access to the network sees which
sites you are accessing and those in
turn can determine your location
therefore it's a very bad idea to go to
porn sites from an office computer by
opening the incognito tab they'll see
your real ip address and unfortunately
for everyone involved the sites you
visited are you surprised
76 of americans who took part in the
survey couldn't even correctly talk
about the advantages of private browsing
private browsing only covers your tracks
on your device the browser won't save
your search queries the results of
filling out forms or the history of
websites visited
this mode is suitable for searching for
gifts for your family members or for
during presentations but no more than
that
therefore we need to go a little bit
deeper right away
follow me
[Music]
[Applause]
proxy server technology is really the
simplest way of increasing your
anonymity on the web imagine that you
want to pass an anonymous note to your
friends
of course to pass it to them with your
own hands is a bad option
your friend is unlikely to believe that
the author of the message is not you
especially if you're the one giving it
to them
therefore you can ask another person to
pass your note on for you proxy servers
work the same way
if you specify the address of such a
server in the network connection
settings then all information between
you and other sites will go via the
proxy the server will play the role of
the intermediary that passes on your
notes and you have to entrust the
secrets in your note to this
intermediary you could ask them not to
tell the recipient who sent the email
if the intermediary agrees with this is
not going to reveal your identity or in
the case of a proxy your ip address
such servers are referred to as
anonymous but if the recipient wants to
find out who the sender was and goes to
the police the intermediary can give out
who the real sender was
some proxies don't even hide the
identity of the sender and these are
referred to as transparent
they can speed up your experience on
popular websites but they can be a bad
choice if you want to use them for the
sake of anonymity
therefore always test the proxy the
easiest way to do this is simply to go
to what is my ip address website and
check if it can find you
[Music]
in addition and in most cases the proxy
has access to the content of the
messages as if you were transmitting a
note without the envelope
therefore the intermediary can read the
contents it's not like they're going to
be interested in it but there is such a
possibility why do we so often use the
services which have such unreliable
intermediaries
first of all it's simple
to use the proxy server you don't even
need to install additional software it's
easy enough to just specify the address
in your browser settings open up a new
window and off you go
secondly proxies are widely available
you can easily find a lot of free proxy
servers on the web and commercial ones
are quite inexpensive
you will be able to choose a server with
your desired ip address and in a matter
of moments you'll be virtually
transported off to singapore or south
korea with this you could significantly
complicate the life of an investigator
if you use a chain of several anonymous
proxy servers imagine that from england
you first connect to a server in india
which transmits your request across to
indonesia and from there the message
goes on to america
to track your actions you would have to
contact all of the intermediaries and
this is a long and difficult process
proxy servers are used not only by
ill-natured intruders however with their
help you can overcome some local
restrictions
for example if you want to watch rick
and morty season 5 on netflix you could
place your location where it's already
available to watch in england however
well we're going to have to wait for
another six months
some users try to substitute ip
addresses to get more favorable prices
for flights and hotels
by the way if you are interested in
testing this method let us know in the
comments below we're thinking about
maybe doing an experiment
[Music]
vpn is the abbreviation of a virtual
private network but what does that mean
imagine for example you work for a large
airline whose branches are scattered all
over the world of course you need to
provide shared access to the ticket
booking system corporate email internal
resources and messengers this could all
be done via public internet but it's
much more convenient to gather all of
these users into one network as if they
were all in the same building
such virtual networks are vpns the
principal operation of a vpn is similar
to a proxy all the information exchanged
with sites on the internet go via an
intermediary server but this time the
traffic is securely encrypted this is
the responsibility of the program that
you need to additionally install on your
computer now if we expand on our little
note metaphor the intermediary this time
will not be able to read the contents of
your notes the only problem is
they still know that you sent messages
to specific addresses and in the case
where the police are on your trail
they'll willingly share this information
with law enforcement in the video we
posted about famous hackers and their
downfalls
bradley talked about the lol set
computer hacking group
one of its members got called on the
basis of sloppy vpn usage
cody recursion kritsinger used the vpn
service with the charismatic handle
hired my ass to hack sony entertainment
service when the fbi were hot on his
tail cody destroyed his hard drive but
even this didn't save him the evidence
remained on the logs of the vpn provider
by comparing the request from cody's
computer to sony's servers and comparing
them with the time of the attack
the investigators received the necessary
evidence
without the hide my ass log it would
have been near impossible to prove
kritzinger's guilt
only active cooperation with the
investigation saved cody from a 15-year
sentence however if you're not aiming to
attack a mega corporation vpn service
will help to ensure a high level of
network security in addition to reliable
traffic encryption such vpn networks
protect against several types of attacks
for example some sorts of phishing
attacks
vpns are also useful if you often have
to visit countries where states restrict
access to certain resources
china or the middle east come to mind
in addition you can build a chain of
several vpns and this will significantly
increase your network security one of
the main disadvantages however of vpns
is their cost subscribing to a proven
and reliable service is much more
expensive than using a proxy
in one of our previous videos we
mentioned that you can get a hold of
free vpns which will provide you many of
the benefits of paid ones however if you
have the choice and the wallet i'd
advise against using free vpns these
services often leak the data of their
users to information brokers and
intruders
for example the provider hola used
computers of its free users to organize
botnets vpn technology was not created
to ensure anonymity this is just one of
the effects of its applications because
of this i'm now going to talk about a
solution that puts browsing privacy at
the forefront of their endeavors
let's go to level 3.
[Applause]
[Music]
the tour is not the name of a
well-renowned norse god but rather the
abbreviation of the onion router it's a
strange name but it does join a long
list of food euphemisms used in tech
the name refers to the main principle of
the network multi-layer encryption in
the wise words of shrek onions have
layers and only by peeling them off one
at a time can you get to the truth
similarly toward networks the
information is packaged and protected by
several layers of encryption
why is this necessary well look at this
all computers that are part of the torn
network are divided into three types
entry node or guard node middle man or
non-exit node and the exit vent our
request enters the network through
several guard notes then it passes on
through the middleman and then finally
to the exit node in fact it resembles a
chain of three proxy servers the main
difference is that the source data is
encrypted three times separately for
each of the network nodes
when a message arrives at the guard node
the program decrypts the first layer of
protection and transmits it onto the
middleman the middleman node removes the
second layer of protection and transmits
it then onto the exit the exit node
finally decrypts the data and sends it
to the internet it really looks like how
we peel onions what does such multilevel
encryption give well two nodes out of
three don't even know what's in the
transmitted message and the one that
does know this information doesn't have
the details of who sent it this
middleman knows which nodes at the input
were connected but it doesn't store this
information as a result a really really
high level of anonymity is achieved the
main disadvantage of this system however
are the low speeds and incompatibility
with several popular protocols therefore
it is not absolutely impossible to watch
a video via tour or download a torrent
but it can be extremely difficult on the
other hand tor is the most secure
platform for the actions of human rights
defenders independent journalists and
dissidents prosecuted by the authority
it was thanks to this system that edward
snowden was able to transmit detailed
materials about how the nsa spies on the
american citizens to journalists at
places like the guardian and the
washington post
this is a little ironic considering that
the basis of toll was developed by the
naval research laboratory which was by
the order of the united states
government
how reliable is tall
it definitely protects you until the
experts of special services are
seriously interested in you
their job is to track the organizers of
drug trafficking producers of illegal
pornography human traffickers etc
sophisticated and sometimes bordering on
genius methods are used in the fight
against these serious criminals
for example
de-anonymization using sound beacons
imagine that you're completely anonymous
you're using a properly configured tour
a browser that doesn't leave any digital
fingerprints and a communication line
protected from interception
everything is great and fine until the
moment you get to the trap site this
site will not try to track your position
ask you to enter any data or get
information from your browser it will
just make a sound
you might not even hear it but it will
still be detected by the microphone on
your mobile phone the application
installed on your smartphone will record
the sound and send the information about
your current position to a special
server
everything is extremely simple
even if one of your devices is
absolutely protected there's always a
high risk that other devices are more
vulnerable
and this type of attack by the way is
called a css device tracking
however such tricks are used
individually to search for particularly
dangerous criminals you're much more
likely to face another danger and this
is called the vulnerability problem of
the exit node if your computer plays
this role you will have to answer for
all of the illegal activities that are
performed through it and it will be
extremely difficult to prove to the fbi
that was not you who tried to hack the
pentagon
therefore if you still decide that you
want to become a colleague of jason
bourne don't forget to visit the tours
client settings and enable a ban on the
use of exit node
[Music]
well as you can see absolute security
can only be achieved in one way never
turn on your computer
the degree of your anonymity depends not
only on your actions but also the
qualification of the guys looking for
you
try to be reasonable and assess the
consequences of your actions if you're
trying to buy a gift online for someone
in your family it's probably enough to
just switch over to your incognito mode
of course over time you will be
tormented by product advertising but
these queries will not be visible in
your search history
if you're going to complain about your
boss online don't be too lazy and make
sure to use a proxy or vpn and of course
don't use an office computer when you're
posting with a vpn you'll be safe airing
all your dirty laundry in public
now if you are collecting information
about the most profitable options for
say wholesale purchases abroad or
collecting data about their
manufacturers use a regional vpn often
the prices for the locals is going to
differ from the prices available abroad
finally if you are planning to take down
the us government or start your own
global drug empire
well just give up
no encryption system no anonymization
technology is going to protect you from
special service agents therefore don't
incriminate yourself do something more
legitimate like trading in meme stocks
my main advice however is to stay
subscribed and up to date with some sub
my name is lucas giving you the
information to survive among the
predators in the digital jungle
[Music]